[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo
atraviesan esta pandemia los cientos de
millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza de hacinamiento
de marginalidad o que se veían expuestas
a conflictos o que tenían que emigrar
hacia otros lugares mi nombre es andrés
suárez jaramillo comenzamos en río de
janeiro donde el boxeo es inclusión una
escuela boxística que suele acoger a los
adolescentes de las favelas de la ciudad
actualmente ha reabierto sus puertas
tras el confinamiento por el coi 19
ahora su misión es la de persuadir a los
jóvenes con un programa llamado del
cerro al ring una estrategia que busca a
apasionar los con el deporte y
desviarlos del llamado que les hacen los
traficantes de drogas la historia a
continuación
hopper con derecho ya izquierdo gancho
al mentón los jóvenes cariocas aprenden
golpes fulminantes entre guantes y
bailes de mohamed alí se baten entre
puños antes que sucumbir a la tentación
del tráfico de drogas cuando se relajó
el confinamiento vimos que nuestros
estudiantes comenzaban con el tráfico de
drogas conversan para
por lo que nos encontramos en
condiciones de reanudar nuestro proyecto
con todas las medidas posibles para
proteger a los estudiantes y a nosotros
mismos
sin aparentemente no hacerse daño todos
los estudiantes disfrutan el ritmo de
las clases con la elasticidad propia de
los latinos bambolean sus cuerpos
mientras lanzan puñetazos a su rival
voy a estudiar mucho me voy a concentrar
mucho tanto en el boxeo como en mis
estudios voy a llegar a la cima y ganar
voy a demostrarle al mundo que no soy
una persona más
para estos jóvenes signados por la
pobreza de sus familias
el llamado del narcotráfico suele ser
muy seductor cuando de hacer dinero se
trata que los niños están necesitados y
no tienen un poder público al que acudir
no tienen ningún lugar donde obtener lo
básico no tienen escuela no tienen a
dónde acudir entonces a quién tienen que
acudir al tráfico de drogas
desafortunadamente es así pero si algo
tiene la juventud es que los sueños
nunca dejan de ser soñados
cuando vengo me siento muy inspirado y
me siento muy feliz
cuando vengo amigo mío y voy a un
campeonato es a otro nivel
esta escuela cuenta con más de 50
estudiantes todos provenientes de las
favelas de río jóvenes que de no ser por
el entusiasmo de sus profesores estarían
a la deriva de los narcotraficantes
decenas de indígenas del estado
brasileño de pará bloquearon una de las
principales carreteras que atraviesa la
selva amazónica para protestar contra el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro estos pueblos
originarios denuncian el completo
abandono de las autoridades para
combatir al cob y 19 que ya ha causado
varios fallecimientos y acusan al
presidente de promocionar la destrucción
de sus hogares con el aumento de la
deforestación veamos el informe de
álvaro cordero
una huelga para denunciar el abandono
del gobierno los pueblos indígenas del
estado brasileño de pará bloquearon una
de las principales carreteras de las
razonas provocando retenciones
kilométricas es su protesta contra la
gestión de jair bolsonaro de la crisis
del comit 19 estos pueblos se sienten
abandonados y consideran que varias
personas han fallecido por culpa de la
falta de ayuda y médicos
desafortunadamente hemos perdido a
personas mayores que eran históricas
para nosotros
eran como museos vivos tenían todas
nuestras historias que lamentablemente
ahora hemos perdido
a la crisis sanitaria se suma la
ambiental en el amazonas' los incendios
han aumentado un 28% desde julio de 2019
algo que bolsonaro desmiente a pesar de
que los datos oficiales corroboraron
esta información esto supone que los
hogares de la tribu kayapó están en
peligro al igual que sus medios de vida
y supervivencia como pueblo esta
manifestación también exige la
protección de la selva tropical desde
aquí se puede ver el humo causado por la
deforestación cada día aumenta y aumenta
desde la llegada al poder bolsonaro ha
apostado por la apertura de la cuenca
del amazonas a la minería y la
agricultura uno de los factores clave
por lo que sus rivales señalan que se
está aumentando la destrucción de esta
región que ocupa el 40% de sudamérica
tras las explosiones que impactaron el
puerto de beirut del pasado 4 de agosto
la agencia para los refugiados de las
naciones unidas- movilizó cerca de 12
millones de dólares para asistir a las
familias de migrantes más vulnerables es
el caso de odette fácil
una de las miles de personas cuyo hogar
quedó completamente destruido con la
onda expansiva de la explosión entre las
ayudas de las cuales es beneficiaria se
encuentran colchones cobijas sábanas
almohadas como un paquete mínimo de
asistencia para las víctimas
mandiá de todas las cosas por las que
hemos pasado nunca había sucedido algo
tan pero tan terrible ni siquiera puedo
dormir en una astrid adam sandler net en
la india millones de jóvenes de clase
media se quedaron frustrados cuando la
pandemia les arrebató esos primeros
trabajos con los que soñaban forjarse un
futuro se trata sobre todo de jóvenes
rurales que tras vivir su infancia de
adolescencia en el campo decidieron
migrar miles de kilómetros a las grandes
ciudades
reales jóvenes que a su pesar regresaron
a sus hogares natal es para esperar a
que la pandemia pase a continuación la
historia de un joven indio que vive este
panorama
así es kumar es un joven que trabaja en
una fábrica en el oeste de india
haciendo cajas para chocolates ferrero
rocher y las cucharillas de plástico que
se encuentran dentro de los caramelos
kinder joy tras ocho horas laborales
ganaba el doble de lo que su padre hacía
en su pueblo natal
hablamos de 13 mil rupias al mes cerca
de 173 dólares
el sueño que quería hacer realidad ahora
se ha a partir de ahora no
puedo hacer nada durante los próximos
cuatro o cinco años hay problemas
relacionados con el empleo y debido a la
economía no obtendremos un aumento o
incluso un salario en el corto plazo por
lo tanto estoy analizando todas las
opciones disponibles y veré qué puedo
hacer que ese aspecto
ahora este joven de 20 años pasa su
tiempo deambulando en la destartalada
escuela primaria donde cursó sus
estudios educado pero desempleado fumar
es uno de los millones de jóvenes indios
que dadas las restricciones de la
pandemia debió congelar sus aspiraciones
de mejorar las condiciones económicas de
su familia
no tenemos ningún apoyo financiero mi
hijo tiene que encontrar un trabajo como
lo hizo antes puede conseguir uno y
empezar a trabajar pero ahora mismo no
tenemos ninguna ayuda económica cuando a
finales de marzo el primer ministro
narendra modi decretó una cuarentena que
se fue alargando paulatinamente el grupo
es uno de italia donde trabajaba acumar
decidió cerrar
cuando llegó el momento de que yo
hiciera algo por mis padres ocurrió este
encierro y todo se volvió loco ellos
todavía se están sacrificando ya que he
estado sentado en casa durante tantos
días sin hacer nada y viviendo de ellos
cuánto tiempo podré quedarme inactivo
también tengo una responsabilidad hacia
mis padres
en india la tasa de desempleo de los
jóvenes antes de la pandemia
correspondía al 17 por ciento ahora el
consejo indio para la investigación
pronostica que la tendencia hacia la
desocupación aumentará con la
contracción del 4,5 por ciento en la
economía que espera para 2020 pero más
preocupante es un llamado efecto
cicatrización que presume que estos
jóvenes aldeanos queden marcados y nunca
más quieran volver a trabajar en las
ciudades
en sierra leona país del occidente
africano a los niños con malaria se les
niega la atención de salud en medio de
la pandemia de kobe 19 se trata de una
persuasión de los médicos locales para
que los padres no lleven a sus bebés a
los hospitales y así evitar los
contagios por coronavirus pero
organizaciones internacionales denuncian
que esto podría llevar a que los niños
con malaria mueran en sus hogares a
continuación la historia desde que
apareció el coronavirus en sierra leona
los médicos de diferentes centros
pediátricos han notado una disminución
en la recepción de pacientes en
principio por el confinamiento y las
cuarentenas
estamos realmente enfrentando una
disminución en el número de pacientes
probablemente por el miedo al cobit y
entonces normalmente los niños que
recibimos aquí suelen ser niños
moderadamente enfermos ahora están
llegando aún más gravemente enfermos o
con mayor retraso según organizaciones
internacionales el hecho de que los
padres no acudan con prontitud a llevar
a sus niños enfermos de malaria tiene
que ver con la alerta enviada por los
médicos locales para evitar mayores
contagios de coronavirus
como no vienen en las instalaciones
nosotros como médicos sin fronteras
decidimos ir a los pueblos
nuestro criterio era ir y evaluar las
aldeas a más de 4 kilómetros de
distancia y los médicos sin fronteras
abrió un hospital en qué nema ciudad de
sierra leona en el año 2019 a pesar de
sus 63 camas los administradores
aseguran estar tratando un 40% menos de
personas desde que llegó el virus a
finales de marzo de 2020
viene con mi hijo enfermo pero ahora
está mejor cuando llegamos no podía
sentarse comer ni hablar pero ahora está
mucho mejor puede comer y sentarse
el colmo agradezco el hospital porque
vivía aquí con mi equipo enfermo y no
pague dinero lo vendieron gracias a dios
la malaria la desnutrición y la diarrea
son las principales causas de muerte
infantil en sierra leona un país que
cuenta con una alta tasa de mortalidad
infantil equivalente a 105
fallecimientos por cada mil nacimientos
de modo que en plena pandemia de
coronavirus la atención en salud se
transforma en todo un desafío
en colombia un artista plástico enfocó
su última obra para exponer la difícil
situación de millones de emigrantes
venezolanos que están pasando meses
difíciles durante la pandemia de kobe 19
con muñecos de plastilina el colombiano
édgar álvarez caracteriza escenas
diarias en bogotá de personas en grave
estado de marginalidad y pobreza al
mismo tiempo el artista ha creado
muñecos caracterizando al virus del cob
y 19 en la capital colombiana que sin
duda alguna ha sido el protagonista de
este año 2020 este es el panorama de los
más vulnerables en esta semana del mundo
gracias a ustedes por seguirnos y
recuerden que más información la pueden
obtener en france24 punto com
[Música]